Hello, everyone.
My name is Andreas Hofheinz,
and today I'm going to talk
about interactive multilayer
maps in Shiny with
the leafdown package.
For my talk, I'm going to use
the Meteostat Weather's Record Keeper
data set, which
contains monthly measurements
from over 2000 weather
stations in the United States,
which measure variables such
as the average temperature
and precipitation.
And the question I want
to discuss in my talk
is how can we most
effectively explore
this data using insights into
how to solve common problems
and overcome the
limitations of simple maps?
When we work with
spatial data, well, it
is usually helpful
to visualize the data
on a map because of the
geographical context
and the intuitiveness
that comes with it.
In this example, we see the
average temperature per state
and already at the first
glance, it becomes clear
that the average
temperature in the South
is higher than it
is in the North.
However, one phenomenon we often
observe when we aggregate data
at higher levels, such
as the state level,
is these hard breaks
at the borders.
Here it looks like
everywhere in California
the average temperature
is quite high.
And as soon as you take a
single step into Oregon,
the average temperature
drops significantly,
which is probably not the case, right?
But the question
is, how can we
explore this in more
detail or in other words,
how can we zoom in?
And one way to do
this is to drill down
to see the data at a
more detailed level,
in this case at
the County level.
In this visualization, we
see that there is indeed
no hard breaks at
the state borders,
but rather smooth
transition, and
that the overall high average
temperature of California
is primarily caused
by the hot South.
So you might wonder why we don't
aggregate the data directly
then at the County
level, and why do we even
bother to aggregate it at the
state level in the first place?
Well, let's have a
look at what happens
when we plot the average
temperature for all
the counties at once.
In my opinion, this
looks quite cluttered
and the overall temperature
trend is not that easy to see,
especially when we compare it
to the state aggregation map
from before.
I'd argue that it is much easier
to see on the right hand side
that the average
temperature in the South
is higher than it
is in the North.
And this is one
reason why it's really
important in many
spatial data analysis
to switch between several
aggregation layers,
to be able to analyze both the
overall trends as well as more
regional trends.
OK, let's return
to our map showing
the average
temperature per County.
Often we are interested not
only in one variable at a given
point in time, but in multiple
variables and the relationship
or the development over time.
So another question
is, how can we
visualize multiple variables
simultaneously using a map?
And one approach to do this
is to embed the map in a Shiny
dashboard and connect
it to other dashboard
elements like charts or tables.
By selecting the regions
of interest in the map,
we can then display additional
variables or the development
over time in the other
dashboard elements.
In this case, this
allows us to analyze
the relationship between
the average temperature
and monthly
precipitation, as well
as the development of the
average temperature over time.
But I don't want to just
describe these solutions here.
I also want to tell you that we
have already implemented them
in the leafdown package.
With just a few lines of code,
The leafdown
package enables you
to quickly create maps that are
embedded in a Shiny dashboard
and have selectable
regions, which
connects the map to
other dashboard elements,
allowing you to visualize
multiple variables at once
as well as the
development over time.
They also have the drill down
and drill up functionality
that allows you to switch
between several aggregation
layers, such as from the State
layer to the County layer,
to analyze the data
in more detail.
And these maps are not limited
to only two map layers.
Instead, we can drill
all the way down
to the very individual
weather stations
and compare their measurements
in the graphs as well.
Allowing the user to
specifically select
the regions to drill down for
avoids unnecessary clutter
and increases the
computational efficiency.
So if you're now interested
in quickly creating
such flexible and
powerful maps by yourself,
I can highly recommend you
have a look at our
leafdown package.
On this slide, I've provided
the GitHub link for you
as well as the key
facts and features.
Thank you very much for your
attention and have a great day.